okay
hi i think we're good to go welcome
everybody
um today's women of impact panel on
reimagining dinosaurs and we've got
three incredible women paleontologists
uh around the world who got london
and united states represented today in
this panel
um and this is going to be about
reimagining dinosaurs but also some
other animals too
not just dinosaurs we have experts in in
other types of
vertebrate animals around so we're we're
doing this today because of
national geographic's october magazine
cover story about reimagining dinosaurs
is just this
incredible overview and look
at all the research that's being done
around the world um in
paleontology that has changed so much
over the past decades it's not
you know necessarily what we're used to
and what most people are used to
seeing there's a lot more technical work
that goes on these days and to quote
michael greshko who wrote the
wrote the cover story as he says medical
scanners particle accelerators and
chemical analyses are letting
researchers
virtually separate rock from bone and
see fossils tiniest hidden features so
that's what yeah that's a great way to
describe what these three women do
my name is shayna montanari i'm going to
be the moderator of this panel today
i am a paleontologist i got my phd at
the american museum of natural history
which
is where i am now is from my background
i'm not i'm not actually there i'm in
phoenix arizona right now
i did my phd there and i did some
paleontological research for about 10
i guess 10 total years and then i'm a
journalist now so i'm a paleontologist
turned journalist
and i have written for a variety of
publications national geographic being
one of them sort of kicked off my
career in science journalism so that's
what i do now
and it's great because i still get to
talk to my old friends and colleagues
and talk to them about paleontology so
i will do a little run-through of who we
have here today to talk to
um and and if anyone watching has
questions
you can feel free to ask them and i will
get some of those towards the end of the
chat probably so
i'll if there's anything i haven't asked
uh you can you can ask it
so i'll start off with yazina vaiman she
is a molecular paleontologist who
researches the chemistry of
fossilization
and right now she is in connecticut
because she is a phd candidate at yale
university
and looking to finish up her degree soon
and we have a doctor bowler minjin
she is a national geographic explorer
she is from mongolia
and the list of accolades for dr minjin
goes on and on
i cannot possibly get through all of
them she famously helped stop the sale
of a mongolian dinosaur in 2012
that had left the country illegally via
smuggler
she is the founder of the institute for
the study of mongolian dinosaurs
and we also have dr anjali goswami
she is now a research leader in life
sciences at the natural history museum
in london and she's an honorary
professor at the university college of
london
she studies the evolution and
development of vertebrates using
very interesting techniques such as 3d
imaging so that's just a
brief introduction you all have
incredibly
long lists of things that you research
and topics you research so we can touch
on a lot more of that into the
conversation but i just have a question
for everybody to start off
i would i would just love for you to
expand on what your primary reef
research focus is first and you know now
that
speaking of reimagining you know now
that is 2020 how has your
research focus and the ideas that you've
dreamed up about how to look at
extinct animals change throughout your
career um
i've noticed that from when i started
you know
15 years ago completely different
questions are being asked and answered
these days so i would just like to hear
about that journey
for for all of you um i guess we can
start with anjali
great and well thank you first of all uh
for inviting me to be a part of this and
i'm really looking forward to talking
with everybody and hearing all the
questions that come in
um so i would say my research is really
focused on reconstructing
the evolution of uh organismal shape or
organismal form
and so we use 3d imaging to um really
capture the shape of organisms usually
their skeletons
especially their skulls actually in
really high detail
and then we use or we develop methods to
um to basically uh quantify
or represent the shape of the skull as
mathematical variables
and then reconstruct how it's evolved
over hundreds of millions of years
and this is um something that's really
interesting both for just understanding
how species evolved and
we can start to look at factors like is
it because of where they live like
habitat or is it what they eat
or is that how they develop are they egg
laying animals or are they live-bearing
animals and how do
all these different factors really shape
the evolution of
how animals look and why some animals
groups are so diverse
like birds and other animal groups are
really not very diverse like crocodiles
um and of course everything in between
which are which are dinosaurs
um and so this was that's what we've
been working on really for about
20 years in my group now um and how
that's changed over the past
few decades that i've been in this field
is pretty immense actually
um so right now what we've been working
on um over the last
you know several years and especially
this year when we've kind of not had
very much
access to our collections is taking
these digital data sets these big 3d
digital data sets
and analyzing them you know with our
computers that we we have at home now
and if if we were doing this five years
ago even it would have been impossible
we would not have had this data
available to us
but just with all the new access to ct
scanners
we have these nice handheld scanners
that we've been traveling around the
world collecting
3d scans of thousands of specimens if we
didn't have that data we would have been
really stuck this year but actually
because of the really the growth in
digital data 3d data
and really the push for everybody to
share these data online
and you can actually get thousands of
specimens from online resources and that
really opens up a whole new world
of what we can do in terms of developing
new methods reconstructing
really the history of life in amazing
detail in a way that just
was unthinkable when i was first
starting out as a faculty member and
certainly when i was a graduate student
how about you guys nina generally i'm
interested
in the preservation of fossil organic
matter of alkynes particularly
focused on biomolecules so when we talk
about biomolecules i mean proteins
lipids
sugars pigments um all
kinds of sort of like molecular
compounds that that make an
organism function and make it look the
way it does and
so i'm not only interested in how they
fossilize and how they preserve
and sort of like what is left after
millions and millions and potentially
billions of years but we're sort of like
exploring modes of preservation and
fossilization to customize
proxies um so basically marker
signatures that
can tell us more about the biology of
extinct animals
and so they were really going kind of
new ways at least i hope so
and we're looking particularly at how we
can use molecular signatures to learn
more about
the relationships about the physiology
about the metabolism
about the behavior of extinct animals
and so the whole aim is
ultimately to paint a more colorful and
more lively picture
of what happened in the past and
ultimately understand how life reacted
in the past major environmental
challenges because i mean i guess that's
something that's very timely
with current situation of global climate
change so yeah we're trying to use the
past sort of like as a
as a molecular key to do a better job in
protecting biodiversity at some point in
the future
and yes if i would have to think about
it like what changed over the past years
i mean i guess
um there has been a lot of of
technological innovations i guess that
kind of like ties right in with what
anjali just said
um so when um we're looking at the kinds
of instruments that people use
to analyze fossils and fossil organic
matter and molecules
that has definitely changed quite a lot
in the past so when i started out of god
as an undergraduate student
everyone was all about mass spectrometry
people are still all about mass
spectrometry
but um we started to explore approaches
that come more from
from in-situ analytics but basically
means that we look at fossils the way
they are without you know grinding them
down powdering them down dissolving them
into something
um we basically like take whole dinosaur
bones and we can analyze them the way
they are
um using methods like infrared
spectroscopy raman spectroscopy
um methods that are really evolving
super fast at the moment and uh
like um going into clinical fields that
are currently growing big and all kinds
of biological
and material science characterization as
on
aspects of aspects of science and so
they get these methods evolve really
fast we get better instruments and i
feel like that is helping a lot
to sort of like move um the
understanding of what preserves in
fossils in
in deep time from looking only at you
know like individual case studies where
we have the
interesting preservation of i don't know
let's say protein residues and one
fossil
to really doing big picture research
yeah
it's amazing what about what about
bullard what are you
you've had a great career i'm sure a lot
you have a lot of to say about this yeah
well
um uh for me it's a little bit of
different story so my research
actually focused on uh mesozoic mammals
so mammals actually live the same time
as dinosaurs
i mean of course you know we focus
saying you know a lot on dinosaurs they
were other
uh vertebrates live at the same time so
one of them is mammal
so the group i uh especially focused on
is called uh multi-tuberculate it means
it has a multiple casps on a teeth
so that's name uh the name is came from
so especially i looked at those group of
mammals from mongolia
because mongolian fossils you know
vertebrate fossils
overall has really nicely preserved
means that you can find like almost
complete skeletons so
if you have a complete skeletons you can
get a lot of data and information
so my focus on was um
basically you know reconstructing family
trip for
uh this mammal group and so even this
group has
known like over 80 90 uh
species being known uh only been known
by
you know partial parts of skull or
teeth you know you know like parts of
the bones
um so because i had you know some number
of uh skeletons from mongolia
that really allowed me to see the whole
skeleton to study
collect the data to make the family tree
much
more um you know information um
in it to to off uh that we can collect
so but of course um for me
um my main focus actually shifted to
more
um advocacy for protecting and
preservation of especially for mongolian
dinosaurs
and and i really really um
dedicated my time to outreach reaching
out to public and kids
and probably will talk that later as i
will share
more things about it
yes i have many questions about that we
and a lot of other things so
i'll keep going so i have some specific
questions that each one of your research
topics sort of remind me of and i guess
i'll
start with uh yes mina your your
research jumps out to me is something
that
you know gosh you know not even that
long ago
15 years ago 20 years ago we would have
been like you can't do that
like that's not that's you can't look at
the chemical composition of a fossil and
have it mean anything and proteins and
the color of feathers and eggs and you
know people would have said no way that
would have been
maybe one of the things that someone
would have said you wouldn't you'll
never really know
what what that is and i'm sure you've
probably encountered
some of that attitude when you tell
people about your research
um you know as the years have gone on
but i feel like probably as years have
gone on people have seen wow like this
is
this is really the real deal and it's
something new and interesting we can do
um you know what what inspired you to
just sort of
look beyond what people thought was
possible
and you know try to and make and make
possible
so like that all really started out when
i was a god very very young probably
teenager me
decided i was always excited to buy
dinosaurs and by previous target life of
all kinds
but i also really love chemistry as a
method and so like when i was a teenager
that was like right about the time when
mary schweitzer was publishing some of
her
greatest articles on protein
preservation in tyrannosaurus bones
things that are sort of like you know
crazy if you think about it like from a
chemical perspective
and that was also right about the time
when jacob winter was graduating from
his phd and was publishing all this
fascinating work on
on on melanosomes and fossil color
so it was really a product of the moment
where i decided well you know i think
chemistry could be actually a very
useful tool to maybe get a better idea
of life
you know in the past and that's when i
started to study chemistry and
fell in love with chemical methods and
ultimately went on to
really become a paleontologist and use
that chemical knowledge
um and yeah i mean i guess you know
like that all started out when um when
ultimately
like i decided to write a thesis on a
more comprehensive topic so i didn't
only want to look at one fossil and
reconstruct the color or look at you
know one particular bond and understand
if there is any kind of molecular
residue preserved
but i wanted to look at everything i
could get from the collection and so i
would just you know pack these like
boxes full of specimens and take them to
the lab and i guess at that point it was
just pure luck
we were lucky to find very very obvious
patterns in our data
and i guess from that point onwards
everything has been more of a
collaborative effort in our field
and i think that's really what we're
changing our perception of what can
preserve in a fossil and what not
this is really a huge team effort yeah
right yeah the team the team effort is a
big thing as you start to use
all these different instruments that are
in different countries and you have to
work
work as a team a lot more than maybe
some paleontologists you know of
days of yore a long time ago ever had
ever had to do that's incredible i mean
i remember reading about
one of your first um pre-prints about
eggshell color
i included it in my dissertation um and
i was like
wow like i didn't you know i never would
have thought about this and i was over
there with the mass spectrometer
um you know for people who don't know
you generally to use those you have to
crush up the fossils so they can be
analyzed which is which is what i was
doing so i was trying not to use any
nice fossils for that but as you're
saying you can do it in situ you can use
the actual bone so you
you have the ability to analyze um
really famous specimens and not damage
them right
yeah i think that is like one of the
really exciting things that comes along
with new technology that you know like
um in in i guess biology and then
medicine it's not that important you
know if you like take a small tissue
sample and you sample it destructively
because
usually there's a huge you know like
like there's a huge resource in terms of
like you know getting tissue samples
getting
i don't know specimen samples from
biological collections because we have
these things around today but every
fossil is sort of like a unique
i guess a unique you know evidence of of
life in the past and you know as
paleontologists i guess
it is like um it's really helpful to not
having to crush up your fossils
especially because it also eliminates a
lot of paperwork with collections
managers
so um yeah i guess another key to like
you know being able to analyze many
faucets at a time reducing the amount of
bureaucracy with it
and simply not damaging the faster yeah
now but it's like so funny that you
mentioned that you read my paper because
back then when i handed in my
dissertation i read your papers on
dinosaur eggshells and icebox
and i actually cited them in my in my
thesis back then yeah
oh that's great yeah we've all worked in
the same circles for
for a long time so it's fun it's fun to
hear that all these years later what
but what comes of it even though i'm not
you're way beyond me now i
i don't understand you're doing it
no like you know i i like talking to you
now more than actually probably doing
research because i can talk about all
different topics so i wanted to
you know ask i guess ask anjali you know
we're talking about reimagining
dinosaurs but as you mentioned earlier
you know you'd work on a lot of
different vertebrates um so if if
someone
like michael greshka who wrote this
article was to write reimagining mammals
um
maybe or you know a different group what
what do you think
um would be some of the main points like
what that you've seen in your
your career oh in terms of mammals i
mean
i think um you know this actually really
speaks to a lot of what bola's been
working on right thinking about mesozoic
mammals in particular i think that's
completely
transformed how people think about
mammals or at least how i think about
mammals right because
you know we always think about mammals
as this like post dinosaur radiation
and you know mammals and birds actually
right so that the um
you know the few times i've really
dabbled in dinosaurs is mainly because
of birds
um and what we think of both birds and
mammals as
yeah you know they were kind of around
the mesozoic but not really doing very
much
and it was really after dinosaurs go
extinct that you see this massive
explosion and diversification
and that's true you know to some extent
i mean there's certainly
this huge diversification that happens
um after
dinosaurs go extinct um non-avian
dinosaurs
um but you know there's a lot of
controversy still about exactly when
that happened
was it really before they went extinct
but also just that you know all these
amazing new fossils that people are
discovering over the past few decades
um show that the diversity of mesozoic
mammals
is so much more extreme than we thought
and especially i think sometimes i think
about the jurassic and i think
the jurassic was maybe the best time for
mammals in many ways right you have this
incredible diversity
in terms of the ecology where you have
these like you know these like
beaver-like mammals and these
gliding-like mammals and all these crazy
mammals running around in the jurassic
um you know so much so much more than
what we thought they used to be when we
thought they were just seeing these
little shrew type things running around
and so i feel like that's like
maybe the biggest and most exciting
thing in in like what's
been reimagined about mammals over the
past few
past few decades really is really seeing
how how they were
you know really incredibly diverse way
back when how that really changes our
understanding of
you know what are the big factors that
really shape their evolution and when
these key characteristics that we think
of as defining mammals when do they show
up and
what drove them to be that way or which
of us i guess we're
obviously mammals which of us to be this
way um so early on
and then that has knock-on effects for
thinking about all the stuff that we
used to think of as being
the key things for mammals right you
know the extinction of the dinosaurs
um you know empty niche spaces you know
that's
certainly a big big factor but but
there's still
a lot of controversy about you know when
these things happen and so
i think that um as time has gone on
maybe we know a little bit less about
recent mammals and more about more
distant mammals than we used to
um so yeah right now i'm just in the
middle of a big project uh
you know working on mammal skull
evolution and i feel like we're at this
point where i'm actually quite confused
about it and so yeah well if you ask me
in another month i'll have a stronger
opinion but right now i think
um i haven't quite figured out what's
going on at the base of uh
the placental mammal tree at least
that's great i mean
it's it's so great that we're just
figuring these things out now and can
use all these new techniques and as you
said you know
large-scale digital data sets otherwise
you know was just
traveling around from museum to museum
coding sessions in a notebook and now
and now look what what you can do and
all the amazing things that that you can
do and just
and i think mammals are going to become
more popular now because i
saw a tweet about the new jurassic park
movie or
sorry jurassic world movie and there's a
list of saurus in it
so there's discipline jurassic world
movie
that will will now come out in 2022 not
2021 unfortunately
i just saw jurassic park um last week
for the first time
what yeah i was the only vertebrate
paleontologist in the world
who hadn't seen it but my kids wanted to
see it so we watched it
well i could turn this conversation into
what did you think of of jurassic park
but i will admit that i also
was not like a huge jurassic park fan i
think a lot of people imagine
this will segue into a question that
someone asked from the group of what
inspired you to get into paleontology in
general
people want to know how you even get
started on this sort of road but
um you know jurassic park came out a
little over 25 years ago now and
it inspired people to get into
paleontology i think especially in my
generation i didn't really watch it
until recently when i performed it
live on stage in in new york city
at a at a club called caveat where they
do science shows
and i was the science expert and i have
the whole script and now i've memorized
it
but before that was only recently so um
that that was an inspiration for people
to get into paleontology but i'm sure
you all have different
different stories about how you got into
paleontology i don't know if um
we'll start with velour how did you
start being a paleontologist in mongolia
well i think my story will be different
because
um even now you know most the public in
mongolia really don't
know much about dinosaurs i mean you
know
around the world mongolian dinosaurs are
quite famous
even velociraptor you know like a
hollywood star
so i think that's the thing is kind of
um
you know story from mongolia i'm when i
growing up
i didn't have much of sources of you
know things to learn about dinosaurs
like a book or
any tv show you know
so fortunately my my father
he was a paleontologist he was actually
one of first
mongolian paleontologists he was trained
in russia
in 1960s so
his uh research was focused on fossil
corals so corals that dated back 400
million years
so mongolia used to be under a
sea back then so we have a lot of
invertebrate fossils can be found in
mongolia
so i had you know i grew up at home have
a
you know bookshelves full of russian
uh books you know so
um so i think for me actually
my interest is really started later on
that um maybe i would say
when i came to us you know after i um
finished my masters which is i focused
on fossil corals but i did have some
interest
i really want to know more about
dinosaurs but it was really limited
even my father he discouraged me to
study
dinosaurs because he thinks it would be
challenging for me
to to learn about anatomy because
i was a geology student so
but i still looking for some
opportunities so i had
opportunity to come to us
right after my masters
that's basically um mangoey just often
to western wall that we had
you know we had opportunity to travel um
you know countries uh except uh soviet
union and you know former socialist
countries
so it really my eye opened in terms of
like interest in paleontology like
coming to us because
there was so many uh sorts of
informations museums amazing museums
here
in the states um so for me
really don't have much of you know
things to say in childhood things
except i've been exposed to you know my
dad's russian books
what about yes you know you said you
were interested in chemistry so is that
did you sort of get
into paleontology that way or was there
have you always liked paleontology and
fossils
so originally i wanted to be a very
traditional dinosaur paleontologist who
goes to the field
brushes dust of bones that are readily
expressed on the surface
and you know like monk skeletons and
museums that was my idea as a kid
um but yeah i have always been excited
about wildlife
of all kinds i love zoos i collected
insects in the garden
yeah it was i don't know i guess like a
very
childish fascination for for life out
there
and so when i was um a little kid i got
i think three years old
according to my mom i don't remember
that at all um
like i desperately wanted to have a book
that had undercover picture
um a couple of dinosaurs fighting and so
according to my mom again this is how
everything started she had to read me
from it every night and
i don't know it's i feel like it's just
like a general fascination with
prehistoric life you know like life
forms that are so different from
anything we see around today
um i think that's just you know
absolutely mind-blowing and fascinating
and so yeah i mean generally i've been
excited about
biology wildlife paleontology
um and then the chemistry kind of
happened along the way
and um yeah for a moment you know i had
like um
yeah i was i was a little bit torn you
know do i want to be a chemist do i want
to be a paleontologist that's my
childhood fascination versus this field
that is really exciting and you know
such a
such an interesting approach to thinking
about problems as we have it in
chemistry um
and i was always thought i have to make
a choice so i graduated from high school
and so in germany you know you have to
pick like after high school exactly what
you want to study
and then you go right into your bachelor
and it's very specialized from day one
and um yeah so i thought you know like
do i want to study chemistry do i want
to study paleontology
i decided i want to go through the paleo
roots so
i had a stipend before to study
chemistry during high school
and for four years i really enjoyed that
and i learned everything about any kind
of method i could
and i decided you know like the types of
questions that really excite me
they are paleontological questions
questions about
um about dinosaur biology
questions about um about you know
terrestrialization
questions about past life and so i
decided okay you know
chemistry you are a wonderful tool but
paleontology has the exciting questions
what about you anjali um i think i'm i'm
quite different from uh
from both of uh you know your other
guests here because
i didn't know that paleontology was a
real thing
as a field until college quite frankly
um
you know i i just it wasn't something i
was kind of aware of
i mean i did have like you know little
cards and books about
fossils like most kids growing up but i
just it never really
occurred to me that that was a real job
with that people could have um
so for me it was very much you know i
always have loved animals i've always
loved camping my parents would take us
camping quite a lot when i was younger
um and hiking and things and so i always
really loved like biology and nature
and so when i went to when i went to
college i wanted to be a biology major
um and i was at michigan and um and
there was
you know there was all kinds of great
classes there so i was a biology major
and um and actually to be honest it
probably comes out
i went to a party my freshman year and
somebody else that was at this party
um we were talking about like camping
and how much we both really like camping
and places we like to go camping
and she said that she was signed up for
a geology class that was eight credits
over the summer
that was um like six weeks out in
wyoming hiking around and camping and i
was like
sign me up that's perfect i don't even
care what they're teaching i don't know
anything about geology
um and i went and one of the one of the
professors was a paleontologist and i
realized that
everything that i liked about biology
was even better when you added time to
it
and so yeah i went back i added geology
as a second major and
i never well i wouldn't say i never
looked back i did take a couple years
out in between undergrad and graduate
school to make sure i didn't want to
stay in kind of more conservation
oriented fields
so i worked in india for wwf and project
tiger
working on tiger behavior and
eco-tourism
but it was in this national park in
india where there was
these amazing triassic outcrops and
so literally every single day i was like
driving around my jeep like chasing
tigers around to see what they were
doing
and like looking up at the rocks like
what is in those rocks
i just feel like if you're like spending
it all day chasing tigers around and
you're looking at the rocks instead
you should probably be a paleontologist
and that's
a good point that's amazing and
like you're looking at the there's tires
you're looking at the rocks but i guess
that
that you found your your true calling
but yeah i love to hear stories about
you know people who who weren't
necessarily wanting to be a
paleontologist from the time they were
a young kid because you know i think
that inspires people who maybe come to
the interest later in life that there's
definitely time
and people ask me the same thing and i
also didn't really know paleontology was
a real thing until college
uh you know i didn't hear about at a
party but maybe you know somewhere else
along the way i didn't really probably
go to it wasn't invited to any parties
but
you know you know i it's it's great
because it's something that you can come
to
come to at any point um and just
i wanted to ask bulwarks you mentioned
it earlier you know part of
what you're doing now as reimagining
dinosaurs is that you're
reimagining the under the way that we
understand it culturally and you're
trying to bring back
um dinosaurs the mongolian people
that have been exported um you know
because as
paleontology progressed in the early
20th century we would
you know in the united states and europe
take fossils back home
to us and you're looking to change that
with the institute of study
of this institute for the study of
mongolian dinosaurs so i would just love
to hear
more about that and what you're up to
with with that these days and hopefully
the pandemic hasn't derailed you too
much
yeah well um uh what happened is
basically you know for me
like first time learning about the
history of mongolian paleontology
was like through um being in a college
in a geology major um you know history
of like
how big international expeditions uh
been worked in mongolia you know it
started like a hundred year ago
our first mongolian dinosaur has been
discovered by um
scientists from american museum of
natural history
so that is basically this uh the
the history starts like in terms of
scientific study you know happened in
mongolia
so all those fossils been left the
country
and so even now it's stored uh here in
new york
m h um so what happened is uh
since then it was quite big sensation uh
when that big discovery happened so that
those were like
you know first asian dinosaurs back then
you know big big
you know discovery stuff and since then
we had
some number of expeditions from uh
former uh socialist countries like
polish and soviet expeditions worked and
also collected a number of fossils they
all left the country
so what happens is all those fossils
left the country and knowledge
also leaves so much
public never been learned about this
discovery
um so they even didn't know even today
as we speak they just
didn't know uh they don't know even we
can find dinosaurs in mongolia
so that's kind of like what's shocking
to me i mean that really started when i
came to
us i'm looking back to my country from
different you know angles see oh gosh
this is what's happening in my country
and all these fossils been left and this
is amazing look at these
very nice museums all around the world
has amazing fossils being discovered
look at all these kids and
families and people come to learn about
this
interesting earth history and so then we
have
amazing fossils how come we left so
behind
so for me was you know through the
graduate school i just
keep thinking of this that i really want
to you know build a museum in mongolia
not as big as m h you know i think we
have
big enough building that we can fill it
up with all kinds of dinosaurs and
other vertebrate fossils we have really
good rich history of fossils
so right after i finish my graduate
school
and i really wanted to change this and
establish this
since the institute for the study of
mongolian dinosaurs so what we do
we basically reach out communities
actually in the small towns those towns
right next to the fossil sites
and so we work with schools they have
you know small schools and
also community members and nomads and so
we really
you know interact directly with them
give the knowledge
what they have in their backyard um
so because they have um like i said
knowledge is left
and so people um um
lack of knowledge and also we had some
economical difficulties in the early 90s
uh people started selling dinosaur eggs
um
in mongolia to tourists right so this is
that
kind of wrap become bigger it used to be
black market now what's happening is
major auction houses you know openly
public auctions happening that anybody
you know
can buy mongolian fossils from auction
houses i mean that really bothered me
so so we really thinks education is
solution we really want to give the
knowledge to
public and you know people in mongolia
they they
they should learn about these uh issues
and problems
and exciting discoveries at the same
time
so um and then the you know i still
haven't left
um i mean you know forgotten of building
the museum i'm actually making quite
progress of
building the museum in the gobi desert
so i run
uh basically an idea that we're going to
launch um
pelanchological program right out in the
kobe desert
and very close to the people who live
there
close to the kids you know make their
dreams to come true
you know if they want to become a
paleontologist so that's what we're
focusing now so we're making
a lot of good progress to build museums
so hopefully
in a few years we have a museum right
next to the fossil site
it's not just one museum we're talking
about multiple museums that we're going
to build because we have
you know very important sites across the
country
really needed protection and you know of
those fossils
sounds amazing i want to can i come
visit when you're done
oh yeah no anybody welcome we really
want you all come
you know and see uh the museum and also
you know you have all amazing knowledge
and expertise that we needed and also we
have some knowledge we want to share
with you
you know so i think it's important that
you know in terms of fossils you know
happen to be finding in mongolia
so we have responsibilities to protect
but
fossils you know in generally overall
belongs to everybody in the earth
because they have all rights to know
about you know what happened back in the
history
so i think for us is we just need to do
you know what we can do and what we're
supposed to do so it means we protect
the fossils share the knowledge
and invite everybody
yeah mongolia is one of the best that's
where i did my dissertation field work
and it's
my favorite place in the world i'm
very happy to hear that yes i miss it
um so actually we have a couple more
questions from the audience and one
is from michael greshko himself um
he has a question for all three of you
or whoever would like to answer this
first so
we talked about some new methods that
you use to look at fossils
this is sort of a technical question but
with how should paleontologists approach
excavation
and preparation of these new found
fossils with all these new technologies
in mind so
you know in the past we may have been
contaminating
something that yasmina would want or
maybe
you know not collecting the fossil
appropriately that's good for 3d imaging
or ct scanning or something like that so
um
are there new things that
paleontologists need to keep in mind
when they're out in the field collecting
specimens
to make it useful for all these you know
new
advanced techniques that you all are
using
i mean i guess i could start off with
just a simple example you know i think
i personally feel like we kind of prep
fossils out of rock a lot less than we
used to
you know certainly when i was an
undergraduate um you know in the in the
you know mid 90s um you know one of the
first things that we did that i did when
i started getting into paleontology it
was working the prep lab and
yeah making sure every fossil was
perfectly um
perfectly prepared and you know there
was no rock left but now
we kind of probably you know if we're
not really sure what's in there probably
shove it into a ct scanner if it's
the kind of right rock type and before
we start hammering away at it
um yeah make sure you don't lose a lot
of the little bones so
yeah i think like that's one thing
that's probably changed so we're we're
probably um not so uh not so
keen to pick away at fossils before we
actually know what's inside the rock
i don't know if that's the rest of your
experience
i would probably like agree with the
same thing and after that
we've recently realized that there are
lots of like really
informative soft tissue residues
preserved in all kinds of fossils but
literally all kinds of fossils
but often these molecular fossils are
literally invisible to the naked eye
so you can have like the most amazing
you know sort of like
biological information recorded in your
fossil but you don't necessarily see it
it just looks like you know like a stain
in the sediment matrix to you
and we just prepare it away and there it
is gone um i mean i think you know the
key to
this recent paper that we published on
on soft shell dinosaurs
was really that very [ __ ] quite often
especially molecular fossils molecular
residues they are super thin
basically invisible people just prepare
it away like the
the reason that we figured out that
these dinosaur eggs were soft-shelled
was because you know people are slowly
starting to
to consider that there may be things
preserved that we can't necessarily see
um not even under a microscope and so
without caution we actually managed to
to find these you know soft residues of
dinosaurs that you would not have seen
at all i mean there is like a little bit
of mineral precipitate on top but
you know anyone would have just prepared
it away and like the the preparator at
amh did like an
incredible job not preparing that away i
don't know how you know
how that was like originally realized
but i think it's just really fascinating
i think there's a lot of
a lot of like paleontological
information and like biological
information preserved in the fossil
record in fossils that we have in our
collections
um and and it's just waiting to be
explored so yeah
don't don't over prepare your fossils
you never know what you're getting out
of them
yeah no i think this is really a
interesting point that you know
especially now
technology is amazing you know compared
then
i mean 10 years ago i think it's
impossible to do you know what are we
doing right now
so i think in probably like you know
thinking that
um i mean digging you know going to
expedition is a really cool thing
right um but now because you know a lot
of technology can be portable
right so you can bring the technology to
the field
and then you know i mean
future probably will we don't need to
dig
we just leave it there and we just bring
all the technologies
and i think it's really you know for
people they really want to see
um the fossils that is in the ground i
mean that's more natural
and if you go to museum in all mountain
beautifully nice
yes and so people think oh this is how
you
find it you know i think that's hard to
really
uh think of you know how to imagine so
um yeah for me in the future probably we
probably stopped collecting
and so fossils would stay in the ground
people come to see
and um even you can do your research
right in the ground i mean there's a lot
of data people usually
you know collect in suit
without touching anything i mean that
could be you know another way
could in a field could go um
and then the same time you know uh
the communities and people in the area
they they have opportunity to see the
fossils in there
you know in the place and not to be
traveling around i mean that's just
um one way could things happen but of
course
we want to show the fastest around the
world i mean there's a lot of traveling
exhibits and things happening
so it's you know really a matter of the
time
in a field can be a little different how
we used to be we used to do
traditionally
can i can i answer that actually it just
reminded me of something that
one of the other things along those
lines of you know the thing like
focusing on the fossils in the field of
course is i think we probably collect a
lot more
context about everything else that's
around the fossils to the other
organisms
get more of an idea of the ecology of
the entire
ecosystem as opposed to just focusing on
you know one individual
really cool fossil where we're i think
bringing much more in from other fields
you know obviously
you know chemistry and things like that
but also really ecological principles
and
you know it's not just about oh is this
a new species it's about well how many
specimens are there what's their
occurrence
data things like that so i think
bringing in a lot more of that
information is
uh far more important now than i think
it was in the past
yeah we're a far cry from the days where
paleontologists would just
if they saw a skull just take that and
just go okay and leave the rest of the i
mean
that used to actually happen you just
leave the post cranials everything
behind the skull
just leave it in the ground and just
take the head and so we've moved
very far far beyond that which is which
is a good thing for
for the field for sure um and so
there's another question from the group
that was sort of about this
topic that is a little you know just
kind of like to back up a little bit
it's just how do we even know
where to go look for for fossils and has
that
i mean has that changed at all i know
you know there's probably some
new ways that we use to identify uh
potential dig
sites um and places to go look for
fossils that aren't already in
collections
i don't know who would who who's been
into the field most recently who
would like to talk about that i know
anjali goes in the field quite a bit
i was in the field in december yeah
recent i suppose
right because you know where else the
last eight months yeah okay that's
that's recently as far as i'm concerned
so how does how did you know where to go
um okay so this is our field site in
south india that we were at
in december and this is a field site
that um you know
had been identified by you know british
geologists back in
you know the days when india was part of
the british empire
um and most of the field sites really i
think around india were kind of first
noted by british geologists saying
oh there's some fossils here um but this
site was especially
noted for things like ammonites and lots
of really um
incredible marine invertebrates um but
a invertebrate paleontologist who'd been
out there mentioned to me that he had
seen some dinosaur bones and some
ichthyosaur bones
um and then it might be worth a look and
so it was about
oh 12 or 13 years ago that we we
made a trip down there i was like um my
collaborator at the university of new
delhi
we went down and just scoured the area
and there was a lot of places where
um you know it was all marine
invertebrates which is cool
but um also you know new sites just full
of
sharks which isn't normally what we're
interested in but you know there's tons
of new species that hadn't been
identified before you know there was a
really nice light with dinosaurs and
lots of other things
um yeah and so that was just a matter of
in order to find our our sites we've
kind of gone through the old uh
geological
literature from the geological surveys
that happened you know a century ago
but also talking to people who weren't
interested in these kinds of fossils but
had gone out there looking for other
things
so i think that's that's part of it and
that's especially important because
you know there's certain parts of the
world that are really well explored
um and there's certain parts of the
world that are really poorly explored
and
in general the northern hemisphere is
far better explored in the southern
hemisphere
so i really focus on uh you know the
southern hemisphere and whenever i say
those people
say like you know that india is in the
northern hemisphere and i do know that
but it was in my head it's the southern
hemisphere continent of course because
it's like gondwana
continent and so really trying to fill
out the gaps and kind of the gun to one
and record especially for small things
so we have really great records of
things like dinosaurs actually from the
southern hemisphere
um but we've done this project years ago
trying to look at
mammal distributions across the globe
and realize that we have so little data
from the southern hemisphere that we can
do anything with any sort of statistical
significance or confidence
and that really drove me saying okay
well there's one little
record from this area let's go back and
look very carefully there
and just use all of our you know new
techniques just take a big team out
screen wash and look for the small stuff
so it's really about going through and
seeing where people may have mentioned
something but never looked very
carefully just really trying to fill in
the big gaps that still exist in the
fossil record
right yeah it's not as much you know
sometimes the jurassic park ground
penetrating radar you
it's a lot of still i guess that hasn't
probably changed too much
over the years it's still looking at the
old literature and
knowing where people may have found
something and just getting you know
doing your investigative
skills on the ground to see who's seen
what where and trying to check those
places out and
it's a good point i guess maybe shifting
more to thinking of new places to look
or places that haven't been explored and
you know at this point hundred even
hundreds of years that may
you know have some some new fossils that
can knock your socks off
in you know in south india that's it
that's that's really awesome so
i know we only have about 10 minutes
left in our in our
chat today so i just wanted to wrap up
um i have a couple questions but let's
see i'll see if i can fit them both in
but
this one could be good to end on in case
we run out of time um i know
a lot of people hear about paleontology
and go i wish i
wish i could do that as a career and you
can so i think
um now especially was as methods of
analyzing fossils of change and the
field has changed
that there's new ways that people can
get into paleontology and new roots i
mean yes mina mentioned
doing chemistry is one way um you know
some
people in michael's story mentioned
they've never really taken many geology
classes they're fully biologists and you
know developmental biologists even so
there's so many different backgrounds
that people have in the field now so
i just wanted each one of you to
recommend just ways that if a student or
someone who wants to become a student is
interested in be
being a paleontologist or learning more
about the field of a student of any age
how how might they go about that and if
you have any specific
advice for for women who are looking to
enter the field of paleontology
can you know splash that in since we all
have experience with
with that um i don't know if yes mina
you would like to start
okay yeah i mean maybe generally like
you know like if you
are excited about like biology if you're
excited about
life around you if you're interested in
what happened to life in the past
or what is going to happen to life in
the future paleontology is probably your
field
um i mean i guess i would recommend
everyone considering that paleontology
nowadays is
is getting more and more integrated and
interdisciplinary i would really
recommend to
um maybe take classes in in sciences you
know like i mean you don't
have to be like a geologist anymore to
be like a really great paleontologist
like some of the most exciting
discoveries are made by people who have
background in developmental bio biology
who have a background in
um in in computational analyses you know
like stuff like that so you know if you
have any
any particular area or topic or a method
of interest
you know like that could be like the
next game changer in paleontology
so um yeah i think that's that's
something worthy considering you know
like take classes in sciences and and
just follow your excitement and your
interests
and i mean i guess then you know the
cure the key to making it through
years and years of study programs is
just you know be really excited and know
that you want to do this and then your
motivation and excitement is just going
to carry you through all that
okay what about what about you balor
what do you tell people who say i want
to be
just like you i want to be a
paleontologist like you well
i mean it really depends like if you are
in the states you have a lot of sources
of information that you can go around
you know even tv show you can see nature
shows you know
and if you live close to even small
museums that has
fossils that happen to have a
paleontologist i think real experience
is really important
and you get more realistic picture of
the field
so i really encourage that if you close
to museums or universities
as paleontologists very first thing is
should meet
with paleontologists and so i think i
mean i'm available
if you want to ask questions you know
i'll be happy to answer you know what
you need and
can direct your right way to you know
right person
but then if you know someone outside in
i mean different countries
you know and then story will be
different like mongolia
you know i do have you know uh students
even young age in high school
ask you know how i become a
paleontologist it's really a hard
question for me
because you don't have enough sources
very few paleontologists
and still very challenging to come to
become a paleontologist
so then comes down academic you know
level yes so i think
you know all uh basic sciences would be
really
good to know even you know knowing math
um um
you know biology uh gel i mean nutrient
yeah biology geology
so you know physics and you know all
these science we use
all those sciences to apply you know in
and to paleontology so i think most
practical thing would be
you know meet with someone if you can
and now you know we have internet social
media if you want to meet someone
like paleontologists you can find them
and we can you know
you can even zoom you know anywhere from
the world
you know probably language can be
difficult but then you know if you know
a little english
yeah so i think it's you know a lot of a
lot of possibilities
yes that's that's really good advice now
it's kind of a good time to get people
because they're probably at home and not
in the field because a lot of times you
email a paleontologist and say oh i'm
you know in antarctica mongolia china
wherever but now
most people are home so it's a good it's
a good time and yeah i definitely echo
that advice is like get
some actual experience um and see what
it's actually like because a lot of
things sound fun
on paper and then if you maybe don't
like the actual day-to-day of the work
um you know you can reconsider but what
you'd like to do
i don't know anjali what do you what do
you think when students ask you these or
you have a new you have a lot of
students so when someone approaches you
and says i want to be a paleontologist
um i think yeah i think one thing that a
lot of people worry about is just that
first kind of
ask but i think i mean there's probably
very few times where somebody has
emailed me and asked about wanting to
you know
maybe help out or volunteer or do a
little research project where unless i'm
just completely slammed or
um you know that i haven't responded or
afforded onto somebody in my lab
to say hey if you're somebody who's
interested maybe you know give them some
data and give them a
give them you know a project that they
could maybe work on or help out on i
think it's
always a really really good idea to do
that i mean certainly you know when i
started out
i you know just walked into a
professor's office
because it was before email was normal
so you know i just walked in and said
like hey i want to be a paleontologist
and they're like okay well read this
paper and come back if you think it's
interesting
um i didn't know enough then to be like
nervous about just doing
that and i think i would have known um
but i think you just
email people email people are really
happy to hear from people who might be
interested in doing some research you
know we've got way more to do than we
could ever
finish and so we're always happy for
somebody who wants to just come in and
give us a give it a try and help out
with the project so i think definitely
email people
you know like everybody said you know
give it a try because research you know
isn't necessarily for everyone and
some people love it some people hate it
it's like marmite right um
on the there's a flip side to that
though which is a lot of people don't
think they can be a paleontologist
because maybe they don't have the best
grades or maybe they're not great at
math or maybe they're not great at
you know biology or whatever um i think
equally you should not let that stop you
because you know i would say i did not
have the best grades as an undergraduate
student actually but i was good at
research and
you know i did a solid job on my
undergraduate project because i got
really into it
in a way just that i just don't get into
coursework um
you know i really just enjoy like the
nitty-gritty of doing a research project
um so you know don't let that stop you
if you're if you're really interested in
doing research
um you know reach out to somebody drop
in line and also don't be afraid to send
multiple emails
i never actually feel badgered um if
people send me two or three emails
because sometimes i'm a little slow to
respond
so do that and be persistent and and
give it a try if you really want to
um and don't let anybody dissuade you
from giving it a try
yes that was really good advice i have
joined the club of you need to email me
probably multiple times if i
don't respond instantly you just then
you have to email me again so i think
that's
that's good advice most of most
professors and researchers are very busy
um so it's good yeah so that's no that's
all great advice and i think it's a
field that
can accept people from a lot of
backgrounds like you said math chemistry
biology physics of developmental biology
so all of these different fields are
welcome um ecology
and you know all these different fields
are welcome in paleontology which is why
why it's so great and
so interesting and also once you're a
paleontologist you can do a lot of other
work
um that's not research like laura does
you know doing these outreach and
starting museums and non-profit work and
i'm a journalist which is
you know it's nice and i mean not
specifically paleontology but just
knowing about science helps you being a
journalist so if you know there's lots
of different directions that you can
take your
your love of paleontology if you if you
have it
so i think with only a couple minutes
left i won't ask another question
because i'll probably go over time
um but hearing from everyone today was
so inspiring and you're all
so amazing and role models of mine and
my career and still continue to be
incredible colleagues and it's just so
great that we could all
get together today and do this and and
have everyone ask questions
so yeah if i guess we can part ways and
some
anjali can go to bed soon because she's
in the uk
i can go eat lunch we're gonna go they
never know what's gonna have dinner so
thanks everyone for for coming to this
talk with these incredible women in
paleontology for reimagining dinosaurs
and see you around
you